bonsoir madame romaine d'abord comment
vous qualifier ce jour avec l'arrivée de
joe biden à la présidence américaine
c'était un moment alors moi j'ai eu le
privilège d'être à l'innovation ce matin
et c'était un moment très très important
bien sûr mais très touchant je crois que
c'est quand même un pays qui qui vit
plusieurs défis très sérieux les
événements d'il ya deux semaines on ont
été difficiles ont été très triste
est ce que nous avons vu aujourd'hui
c'est un président mais aussi
l'entourage et y compris paiement du
sénat les membres de la chambre qui
était là avec lui des deux partis
politiques qui voulaient vraiment
démontré que les américains à les
préserver et souvenirs leur démocratie
même face à un défi très difficile
quel sera l'effet de l'arrivée de joe
biden sur les relations économiques
commerciales du canada avec les
états-unis ont en général et je crois
que ça va être très positif les notre
gouvernement et l'administration byden
ont les mêmes priorités c'est-à-dire une
reprise économie pour nos pays qui
avantage les travailleurs qui met
l'emphase sur les emplois qui
responsable du point de vue écologique
1 et aussi c'est un administration qui a
dit et plusieurs fois et encore
aujourd'hui qu'ils respectent leurs
alliés qui respecte les règles
internationales les normes
alors je crois que ça va être une
relation commerciale est beaucoup plus
prévisible est beaucoup plus sécuritaire
ouais vous dites que les priorités sont
semblables mais le premier lieu des
premiers gestes de la journée de joe
biden c'est de signer qui on a les
images à la maison blanche en fin
d'après midi aujourd'hui signé
décret pour retirer le permis pour le
projet keystone xl est ce que la
relation entre le canada et les états
unis de joe biden ne s'amorce pas quand
même sur une mauvaise note avec ça si
certains que nous sommes déçus par cette
décision et ça fait ça fait dix mois que
moi et mon équipe ici à washington avait
que nos collègues à ottawa avec le
gouvernement de l'alberta avec
l'industrie avec la compagnie si angie
nous essayer nous faisons preuve valoir
notre point de vue sur ce projet et
notre but c'est que c'est un projet qui
a des bénéfices et des avantages pour
les américains qui sont importants mais
ceci dit c'était un promesse que le
président bailleul a fait dans sa halle
au cours de sa campagne électorale
oui et il ay la ilaha illa va de l'avant
avec sa promesse
voila voila chercher ça mais vous écrire
est ce que vous laissez tomber
est ce que vous laissez tomber le projet
qu'ils se trompent parce que ce sera
difficile de le convaincre de changer
d'idée à partir de maintenant je crois
que c'est une décision
il faut que nous nous tournons vers le
futur alors se tourner vers le futur
c'est vous a laissé c'est donc les
pressions sur piste en excellent et
c'est une décision claire qui a été
prise comme je vous dis moi j'ai eu
beaucoup beaucoup de conversations là
dessus avec même avec l'équipe hayden
les gens qui sont très hauts placés dans
l'équipe hayden et c'est une décision
claire et ferme de drogba est de mise
aussi sur un plan made in america
un plan qui pourrait être vu comme étant
protectionnistes qu'est ce que ça
signifie pour le canada
ou alors les chronos protectionnistes
chez nos voisins ça existe un peu
toujours en dehors avec les
gouvernements gars notera les
gouvernements républicains
ça se soulèvent souvent mais au niveau
des états ça se soulèvent souvent nous
allons bien sûr souligné le fait qu'on
vient de renégocier l'alena et danser
renégociation à la au fond de cette
entendre là c'est le principe qu'une
commerce qui est prévisible qui est
basée sur des règles qui sont claires
une commerçante renoue quais ouverts
assez important pour les deux pays nous
avons deux milliards de commerce entre
les états unis et le canada à tous les
jours as he has et un commerce que
soutient des millions et des millions de
tracts d'emplois des deux côtés de la
frontière
le président by dell y met l'emphase sur
les emplois des américains et le
commerce entre le canada et les états
unis qui ouvert qui est prévisible
ça contribue à ces emplois là dans
l'ordre nous allons amener tout ça sur
la table nous allons vraiment montrer
les faits juste pour dire si je peux
continuer à les hits nous avons vécu
très récemment dans le contexte qu'ovide
une expérience très réel là dessus alors
dans au printemps au début de la
pandémie
il y avait des perturbations dans nos
chaînes d'approvisionnement entre le
canada et les états unis pour les
produits médicaux et il y avait chez
certains ici aux etats unis
l'idée que de perturber ses chaînes
d'approvisionnement ça allait contribuer
à puce de production qu'elle est resté
aux états unis mais en fait le contraire
s'est passé web c'est c'est quand ces
chaînes d'approvisionnement qui sont
très intégrés ont été cassés qui ont été
perturbés on voyait qu'il y avait moins
production disponibles pour les
américains au moins de production
disponibles pour les canadiens une fois
que tout ça c'est réglé
des deux côtés on voyait au contraire
une re lancement de la production
il met au service de madame yvonne il
nous reste quelques secondes
est ce que vous vous attendez à ce que
les états unis de joe biden rejoindre le
partenariat transpacifique a tout de
suite mais ils ont été assez clair là
dessus avant l'heure pendant leur
carrière après l'élection que c'était
pas une priorité pour l'instant nous
allons voir ce qu'elle vaut mais non
vraiment c'est le combattre le co lead
c'est la relance mans ce sont des plans
être plutôt d'investir dans un
environnement merci beaucoup et monia
bonne suite des choses pour vous
remercie dieu merci bien pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit